like the BAM situation I wrote it down
to talk about
um
dude well because I I posted this
this comment on Bam's
Instagram
because I was just like like I just had
him on tour with me for for 10 days we
did nine shows together
he was really pretty great the whole
time he's funny he's fun he was a he was
a good guest right and
the the last the whole time he was
telling me like dude we reach out to
Nikki his his wife his baby mama we
reach out to Nikki and see if we if I
can spend the day with Phoenix you know
I want to see Phoenix because where our
last show of that run happened to be
Santa Rosa California which is super
close to where Nikki was
and and his son was so like that that
was it was like this whole leg of the
tour 10 days nine shows just culminated
it was just a big journey to his son and
sure enough on that last day bam was
reunited with his son you know uh we all
spent the day together it was a great
day we did the the last show that night
and it was a big deal because bam had
been practicing
um you know opening the show with me and
working up to going out on stage by
himself and he did that he went upstairs
it was like kind of triumphant not only
did he go out on a stage by himself but
he brought his five-year-old boy with
him on stage and it was just this like
heartwarming wonderful thing and then at
you know at the show kind of Backstage
after the show
um it was determined that bam was like
okay bam you're doing great like his his
uh baby mama Nikki says like you know
what like let's like uh let's give this
a shot we'll spend another day or two
you can spend another day or two with
your son and she's like yes awesome
Bam's gonna be reunited with the sun and
then for him to go and like leave the
the the the theater that night and like
it's come like four five six in the
morning he's posting like hateful stuff
about Knoxville and Tremaine like it's
it's like really dude like you know what
that means every time he's posting like
resentful stuff about Knoxville and
Tremaine it's a terrible sign
he admitted that it was because he was
drunk and it's like dude come on man
like I was just so
bombed you know I was you know I was
equally disappointed as I was
unsurprised because that's the nature of
the the disease you know but like I was
just so struggling with that and so I
went and and it also kind of felt like I
beared some responsibility for his
hateful post about Knoxville and
Tremaine because it was like it was sort
of like that happened under my watch you
know like oh you're gonna cart bam
around on tour and like you're okay with
this and like not that I didn't care
that much but you weren't even with them
you were he was in the same brand yeah I
wasn't it was as soon as I wasn't with
them that that's what happened yeah and
uh and so it was just bugging me man it
was bugging me all day and uh his his
hateful post had been up for 22 hours
and I was just like ah you know I was
just like so I couldn't write this
comment on there like you know it's
saying like largely what I just said now
but uh and I wrote it and I was like
dude you're dying bro like you're dying
and it just sucks because like I you
know I want to like save you but I can't
do that you know like I can't make you
want to get better like like uh I can't
do the work for you you know and so I
write this whole comment and I just
posted it and then I showed it to Lux
and luck says that's not a public thing
you shouldn't and I'm like yeah you're
right should I delete it
that comment had been up for literally
two minutes two minutes and the post
that I commented on had been up for 22
hours it wasn't like brand new in
everybody's feed plus it was on Bam's
like secondary Instagram the one that's
actually him which has a way smaller
audience not Captain Captain
was the one that I posted on two minutes
and I took it down and then the next day
TMZ reaches out hey is this real look
dude that thing went [__] viral and
then it's on like yeah dude page six TMZ
Yahoo news like it like I I really
didn't
care for that to be the case it wasn't
my goal to to make all that happen yeah
once the wheels are in motion you're
like [__] it yeah but that's it means
how I feel you know it's how I feel and
and I didn't want this podcast to be
about that you know like but uh but
they're like um yeah I was just curious
about that yeah I I wrote it down as
something to talk about and now uh have
you talked to him you know I I had some
texts with them I said you know bam
we've got those boards and and we could
still sell a ton of them but uh what I'd
really like to do is open up a trust for
your son and have money go into a trust
and that got no response that's no
response there
um of course since then I you know the
news was on TMZ that that Nikki has
filed for legal separation and spousal
support
um so I I'm feeling kind of inclined to
uh
how help everybody involved by uh you
know moving forward with those boards I
think that it'll be good for his son
it'll be good for his baby mom it'll be
good for him and um I'm not in any quick
and I'm not in any rush to do it but um
I think that that's something that would
that we should
probably go ahead and do yeah all right
it was nice having her on tour though
when he was it was happening when he was
good I loved it I remember we went to
the Nike store and uh in Portland and I
was like oh dude you ever like uh ride
for Nike he's like yeah it was the first
skateboarder to ever ride for Nike I
mean just the stories that he had going
through Portland was I mean he's
what a lot of people don't know about
him is like dude he's a great [__] uh
driver to like uh be in charge of the
music there's always good music going on
he's kind of like a a teenager in a fact
where he's like he's he's always trying
to make jokes and do funny impressions
like he did he's different than what I
always thought he was he he's playful
he's playful he's playing full and uh
dude I love him man he's he's a brother
you know and it's crazy how like that
whole lawsuit situation with him suing
jackass
and every you know
it's like it really really put a a
strain you know like his whole
relationship to jackass with the the
director Jeff Tremaine has a restraining
order against him so they cannot have
contact like legally how long do
restraining orders last forever forever
yeah I have no idea but but from what I
understand it's still in place and you
just can't sue somebody and then turn
around and be Bros with them yeah you
know but like I'm in this position where
I'm ah like
I'm uh
Switzerland yeah I'm the one guy who has
been cool with bam all along you know
and even though I've never sugarcoated
anything you know and and whether I'm
okay with bam still kind of remains to
be seen yeah you have a weird
relationship with bam where you can be
harsh to him and he just listens to you
yeah
anyway I I think that I do still that we
are still all good
um
moving on I didn't I just wanted to say
some positive things about bam because
he really it was he's fun and he's funny
and he's [__] he's great to hang
around plus dude that kind of stuff you
know even having put on like a
substantial amount of weight like
I thought man I thought like at this
point man I think I can take him and I
cannot outskate bam well yeah Burnside
yeah yeah it's funny than that that
fight at Burnside you saw the fight I
was not there for that you weren't there
for that I went to Burnside the next day
yeah I don't even want to because like
it was just a trip that like these two
guys got an argument one guy pulled out
mace and then they grabbed the mace from
this guy and mace the guy who pulled it
out his face
they pepper sprayed him with his own
pepper spray and I wanted it as they
beat him up yeah well and I was like man
dude like this would be great to have on
film and then you look around and
nobody's filming and I'm like I'm not
gonna be the [__] [__] to film and
then the cops came and but anyway it was
just a good experience all around in in
the Pacific Northwest was bam right bam
we miss you come back
it was epic I love bam
and uh and you got a video coming out
yeah we're working on a video do you
like shopping on Amazon I do and good
news is Stevo's butt wipes for your
butthole are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole plus Stephen's butthole
destroyer and Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right now
yeah dude